in tonight's pulse of the nation we
examine not just the current political
mood we also are taking a then and now
look at things I thought that would be
fun to do tonight and what we see is
pretty foreboding for the Democrats and
to help us understand this well our good
friends at CNN in January 2020 55 of
respondents thought things were going
very or fairly well in our country today
under Biden that figure is just 29 now
in January 2020 Trump had a 55 approval
rating on the U.S economy today Biden is
at 37 percent
and at the end of 2019 before covid a
whopping 76 percent of Americans thought
the economic conditions in the country
were good
well today
only 25 of the country
joining me now is Mark Penn former
Clinton advisor and pollster and Fox
News contributor as well as Tom Bevin
co-founder of RealClearPolitics
Mark the country is saying it pretty
clearly
they don't like this economy they don't
care how the Biden team is spinning it
and they keep saying the same thing and
they keep thinking on the Democrat side
this is a messaging problem where does
this end up
well I looked at this recently and look
people are really upset about inflation
they feel their purchasing power
particularly in in food and gasoline
crisis has really been eroded and
they're giving the president about a 35
rating on the economy but that doesn't
mean a year from now when when really
people have attitudes that go to the
election it will be the same as your
polls point out voters can change a lot
in 96 for Clinton we changed it about
180 degrees in the six months so right
now things look quite bad for this
Administration in the economy but a year
from now who knows okay but Mark Mark
wait a second you had Bill Clinton one
of the best politicians we've seen in
the past 50 years in American politics
so comparing Clinton to Biden who's
still trying to find him his way off a
stage I'm not sure that's an app
comparison but I give you kudos for
actually trying to make that comparison
all right
um Bevin on another interesting note
Republicans are outperforming Biden on
the handling in the economy specifically
Kevin McCarthy and his leadership by
about nine percentage points again given
the fact that the economy is the number
one issue in every single poll is that
significant
yeah sure I think it is I mean uh the
economy in this poll was the number one
issue by four to one over the next uh
the next issue on people's minds almost
50 percent of people so it Remains the
dominant figure and will be for the
foreseeables future unless something
happens some event happens in the next
year the economy is going to be what
this election is about and so for
Republicans to have an edge on that as
Mark said it could change obviously
depending on what happens but for right
now uh they are in in better shape than
Biden right on the economy now the
energy prices are going back up courtesy
of the Saudis um Mark CNN
um of all places seems to be kind of
realizing that maybe their candidate
isn't the best watch
we don't know how solid a candidate Joe
Biden is we know he's not a solid kick
exactly he's struggling I mean it is
hard to watch right why is Joe Biden
running for reelection I mean this is
crazy
Mark um do the Democrats have any other
realistic options at this point I mean
everybody seems to want different
choices here I guess but
um any anyone else out there
um interestingly Joe Biden seems to be
consolidating his support among
Democrats he's in the 60 plus percent
range when I ask now who do you want to
be the Democratic nominee he's scoring
much higher than say Donald Trump is in
the Republican party so no I I don't
think there's going to be another uh
switch here within the Democratic party
if anything he seems to be consolidating
the Democrats and the action is going to
be over on the Republican party is Trump
going to really consolidate him or is
the Republican party going to fragment
um let's talk about what happened with
Obama's conversation uh recently as
reported that he was basically telling
the Democrats and Biden don't
underestimate Trump now again Obama is
one of the best political candidates
we've seen in the last 50 years as well
commenting on Trump that way what did
that tell you Tom
well I mean we see a lot of chatter
about this I mean look the national
polls right now for what they're worth
are within a point of each other uh
Biden has a less than one point
advantage against Donald Trump and
that's nationally you look at some of
these swing States uh and it's probably
even closer so I think everybody
realizes that a Biden Trump match-up is
going to be a very very close election
just like 2020 it's going to come down
to the same States a handful of votes
and it's going to be hand to hand
comment and I think anybody who thinks
that Donald Trump doesn't have a chance
even if he's indicted uh you know a
fourth time even if he perhaps is
convicted
um and is on appeal I think they're
deluding themselves these bases are
really locked in right now and it's
going to be that way for the foreseeable
future all those unpaid parking tickets
those are going to come due as well so
we'll see how that affects the election
Mark and Tom good to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else